how top gun Maverick stole 1.3 billion
dollars by copying Star Wars for
starters the characters in Star Wars A
New Hope and top gun Maverick are eerily
similar they both feature a young male
protagonist whose father died when they
were children with rooster as the
protagonist and Top Gun and Luke
Skywalker as the protagonist in Star
Wars they're both watched over by an
older man who eventually trains them
this Mentor was also best friends with
their father and can be found in the
characters of Maverick and Obi-Wan
Kenobi and each of the stories the
protagonist wants to follow in their
Father's Footsteps and they become one
of the best pilots in the world or the
Galaxy later in the film they're engaged
in a super dangerous mission to destroy
an enemy weapon of mass destruction
whether it be a uranium refining
facility or a world-killing death star
their missions both until a low altitude
high-speed Trench Run made in an effort
to avoid anti-aircraft weapons both have
to hit a small ventilation shaft but I
will say that we found our first
difference between the two movies
because Rooster's ventilation shaft is 3
meters wide while Luke's was just two
meters wide